- Hey, everyone, and I hope
you're having an amazing day.
It's Mark Wiens, I'm in Bangkok, Thailand,
and just sitting down for a
really simple, quick lunch.
Look's like a donut fried egg.
Oh, the yolk, take a bite, get chilies,
there's basil on here.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, that's delicious.
But ever since I took a trip to Pakistan,
which was really, it was
the trip of a lifetime,
I have been wanting to
go back to Pakistan.
(bottle hisses)
Welcome to Karachi!
I'm very excited to be back,
and I wanna say huge thank you to Pepsi
for sponsoring this video.
Today, actually in this video,
we are going to go on
an ultimate Western Pakistani
continental street food tour!
We're starting in Karachi,
we're gonna go to Islamabad,
we're gonna go to Lahore,
we're gonna eat burgers,
the chutneys are gonna flow,
it's gonna be some amazing food
that I'm gonna share everything
with you in this video,
and again, a huge thank you to
Pepsi for making this happen!
(excited music)
We just arrived to a place
called Nursery Burger.
Oh, you could smell the
burger fumes in the air!
(music jams)
Their burger production at
Nursery Burger is so impressive!
Just watching so many
of the Pakistani dishes
three different types that you can order.
You can order the beef chapli,
which is like a hamburger,
you can order the chicken chapli,
which is like a chicken burger,
and then you can order the vegetable,
which is, looks like a potato patty.
Those all go onto the hot plate,
then on the other side of the hot plate,
he takes a swipe of chutney,
puts that onto the bun,
then he loads it up with
a mixture of onions,
and it looks like there's
some coriander in there
and maybe some slices of beetroot!
(restaurant chatter)
(groovy music)
He cuts it in half.
Immediately, that goes onto,
like scooted off the
hot plate onto a plate
and then they squeeze on both a chutney
and then tomato sauce onto the
plate that you could dip in.
- We are so glad to have Mark back,
feels like a dream, but always reality.
- Reunited!
Joel is here.
- Oh, so beyond excited, beyond
words, literally right now.
- We're so, yeah, it's so
great to be back in Pakistan!
Again, the warm welcome,
we're starting with super,
not just Nursery Burger,
this is the Super Nursery Burger.
I'm going for the beef chapli burger.
Oh, the chutneys, there's
more chutney down there
in that handful of onions and coriander,
and then I think that's even beetroot,
and then the patty, you
can see how tender it is,
the lettuce is on there, the tomato.
Look at that cross section!
- [All] Cheers!
Cheers!
- Oh, wow, the spices in the burger,
the chutney, you taste the
coriander seed in that meat.
The burger is perfectly soft
and crunchy on the edges,
the coriander seed, that
is the noticeable effect.
But, we gotta dip it in that chutney,
and when I mean dip, I
mean like a full swipe.
- It's amazing.
Shata rules, man.
- (appreciative grunting) The
chutney is a little bit spicy,
you really taste the onions in it,
and mint, I think it's
mint in the chutney, right?
Taste like, really
refreshing from the mint.
Thank you!
(excited beat)
Oh, there's a chunk!
(laughter)
It is so good, it's
all about that chutney.
Jean, how's the burger?
- It's very good.
- The combination of
the chutney, the bread,
the texture, the patty!
This is literally the type of place
you just want to sit for the
rest of the afternoon in,
just order burger after
burger, because it's so good!
It's so tasty, but we gotta
move on to the next place.
(happy music)
Next place that we're
going is called Hanifia.
It's an establishment in Karachi,
and I'm not even totally
sure what it is, yet.
We're gonna find out, but
it's called Hunter Beef.
This place is typically more busy,
and just packed at night.
We're here in the middle of the day,
but they said they could make it for us.
- [Chef] The beef.
- [Mark] This is Hunter Beef?
- [Chef] This is Hunter Chicken.
- Hunter Chicken.
He just sliced the bun,
and he's just toasting it in
a hot drawer down below there,
but Hunter Beef, it's the
Pakistani version of corned beef.
Buns are coming out.
Just puts a good amount of
the Hunter Shredded Beef
onto the bun, and then
he added on a tomato,
a slice of tomato, a slice of cucumber.
The meat actually comes from the bowel,
stomach section of the cow.
Oh, it's kind of heavy!
Like, a half of a Hunter Beef.
Let's see that cross-section.
I think you lost your cucumber.
(laughs)
It's bacon-y, like the flavor of the meat
is not that pronounced, like corned beef,
but not as salty, milder in taste.
To me, it's not quite
as tasty as a burger.
All right!
(paper crunches)
(tuneful drum beat)
(street chatter)
- Thanks.
- Thank you, nice to meet you!
Very nice to meet you!
- Pakistan!
- [All] Zindabad!
- Thank you very much!
- Thank you so much!
- Thank you, thank you!
We just stopped by the
Muhammad Ali jinnah,
which is the mausoleum.
He is the founding father of Pakistan,
and he's one of the most respected,
one of the most revered persons
in the history of Pakistan.
We took some selfies, we took some photos,
that was a great experience.
We're on our way now to eat the next.
Ali, what are we eating next?
(laughs)
(excited beat)
Naans, cloud naans, cloud nine of naans?
Is this the Philly Cheese Steak?
- [Ali] Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- That's the one, so what they do is,
they take every kind of stuffing
and put that into the naan.
Chocolate, cheese, potatoes, whatnot.
- Not quite pizza, but like calzone style,
so he has the base, he fills
it with the ingredients,
it's gonna be the Philly Cheese Steak,
and the other things that we got,
loads it up with cheese!
Oh, here comes the first
ingredients, the Oreo one!
(chiming music)
Fully-loaded ingredients on top!
It's like, packed, stuffed,
and then he puts on a top
layer of dough, of naan,
and then that goes into the oven,
and they have a full wood fire oven.
That smells so good!
(excited beat)
I love how he just tosses
them into the oven,
and then he works that.
You can see the bubbling
up immediately, blistering.
But I love how this
place is totally set up
like a pizza, a take-out
pizza joint, pizza place.
The boxes are all ready to go.
(crusty bread crunching)
- [Jean] Wow, that's nice.
- That's the Philly Cheese Steak.
All of the naans are ready.
We got five different versions.
This is the one that I
really wanted to try,
which is the Philly Cheese Steak.
We also got the sweet one,
we got the chicken shawarma,
we got the, I think this
is the fried chicken one.
He cut most of the others,
but I think the Philly Cheese Steak...
(laughs) Oh, you could
pick up this whole thing
and just bite it! (laughs)
Okay, no, I will tear off.
Oh, that beef in there, the cheese,
oh, that does look wonderful.
Every naan comes with
their own sauce as well,
but I'll just try it first.
Oh, wow!
O-la!
That's it, right? (laughs)
- Aala! (laughs)
- Nice.
- Aala!
It's like a tangy barbecue sauce.
The cheese, that is Pakistani
Philly Cheese Steak naan,
and that's awesomely good.
Which one is that?
- It smells awesome!
I love the green peppers and
the steak is quite tender.
(bottle hisses)
- (laughs) 'Cause I dropped it!
Yeah, I wanna try the
chicken shawarma next.
The piece is absolutely stuffed
with chicken and cheese,
and this one needs to be sauced.
That does taste exactly like a shawarma.
- Really good.
- Cloud Naan has offered
a variety of naan.
- [Ali] Yes!
- [Mark] Yes!
(sizzling)
(restaurant chatter)
- [Mark] Yeah, yeah, this is the story,
the Mr. Burger story!
So we're at a burger franchise restaurant
that is very well known,
especially in Karachi,
called Mr. Burger, and as the story,
pretty much the story is that
the brothers went to America.
They worked for a fast food franchise,
and they wanted to bring
it to Pakistan, to Karachi,
but then they got turned down.
- Exactly.
- They got turned down,
so eventually they had an idea, they said,
we're gonna make our own
burger franchise in Pakistan,
and that was back in 1980.
Then, they opened up their own franchise,
they opened up their own Mr. Burger,
and we're about to taste this.
So, it has a unique story in Pakistan,
it's a very well-loved, very well-known
hamburger restaurant in Karachi.
And is it only in Karachi,
or all over Pakistan now?
- Only in Karachi.
- [Mark] Only in Karachi, okay.
How many branches are there in Karachi?
- Ten, ten.
- Ten branches, ten branches, cool.
I'm gonna order the Mr. Big.
It's a double patty, double cheese,
double onions, double everything.
It looks pretty good.
(easygoing jam)
The wind just blew off
my ketchup containers,
okay, that's all right, though.
Let's unwrap this.
Oh ho ho, the cheese is oozing,
oh, that does look like
an amazing burger, though.
The cheese is oozing, the double patties,
I love how they put them
pickled, vinagered onions on it
as they just sizzle away on the hot plate,
then some of that hot sauce,
some of their own hot sauce.
- [Ali] And the mustard!
- And the mustard, yeah,
the mustard and ketchup
goes on as well on the bun.
Oh yeah, that beef.
Oh, another cool thing is that they use
100% pure Pakistani beef,
so this is a a real
Pakistani fast food burger.
(appreciative grunting)
Oh wow, that's pretty good, actually.
The beef immediately stands out,
like it's all about, you really taste
the quality of the beef
and the crumbliness of the beef.
(appreciative grunting)
Yeah, the beef, the freshness of the beef.
- [Ali] Yeah, exactly.
- [Mark] Okay, who wants to try it next?
- Your first bite, I
saw it juice a little,
and my saliva glands started working.
(appreciative grunting)
- I want a bite, too. (laughs)
I want a bite, too.
- [Mark] Feed the man!
- Feed me, feed me.
(laughter and appreciative groaning)
- [Mark] You gotta try the Mr. Burger.
You should try.
- Hey, the fries are good.
- This is really good!
- Yeah!
- Haven't you tried that before?
- Nope!
- Would you like to?
(laughter)
The final place that we are at tonight,
and the final place that
we're gonna eat at in Karachi
before we move on to Islamabad,
is called Biryani of the Seas.
And by the way, I just want to
point out the sin-styled hat.
We ordered a seafood platter,
I think it's gonna be served
kind of platter style,
but there's fish, there's
crab, there's gonna be shrimp,
and he is marinating
them in two different,
one is spicy masala, one
is a more mild masala,
but a green chili masala.
(sizzling)
I think he brushed on some oil,
and then that just, the smoke just lit up,
and now he's fanning it out.
That smells so good,
standing in a cloud of smoke,
but they're really slow grilling it
so that it cooks, it doesn't burn,
but cooks through it
and that just has that smoky taste to it.
- Baryani, two fish.
- What do you want to start with?
(laughs)
Let's start with the fish, okay.
- [Joel] Oh, that's so soft, oh my god.
- Yeah!
- Yeah! (laughs)
(appreciative grunting)
That's masala, that's like liquid masala,
that it is marinated in.
You taste a little bit of
the dried chili in there.
It's delicious, it's
wonderful, and so smoky.
- Almost like roasted black pepper,
it's really wonderful.
- Again, with the shrimp, we
got two different marinades.
The green and the red masala,
and I think this should be a
tamarind dipping sauce, yeah?
Immersion.
(appreciate groaning)
Oh, that's wonderful,
so springy in texture.
And that red masala marinade,
for me, that's the winner.
Because they have masala,
has just caked on,
there from the grill,
it almost looks fried.
(crunching)
- Oh yes. (appreciative grunting)
Oh wow, that's awesome, like,
it's kind of dried out, dehydrated,
and then all that masala has just caked up
into the meat, onto the shell.
They have really, really good masala here.
It's been an amazing day in Karachi.
We've met so many amazing people,
eaten some amazing, the
food has been delicious
on this western, Pakistani,
continental food tour.
The buns, the burgers, the seafood!
See you in Islamabad!
(laughter)
Oh, sorry, Ali!
- Please take me to
Islamabad, it's my scene,
you're gonna take me anyway, take me.
- Welcome to Islamabad!
(happy music)
First place we're going to in Islamabad
is called Najeeb Spot,
and they are very well-known
for their Afghani burger.
(chill groove)
- Beef sausage?
- [Mark] Beef sausage!
- Chicken!
- [Mark] Chicken Sausage!
(car horns)
What is that?
Masala?
- [Chef] Afghan chutney.
- [Mark] Afghan chutney?
- [Chef] Yes.
I'm adding ketchup.
- [Mark] Whoa.
- [Chef] A bunch special chicken.
- [Mark] He added on some masala,
he added on some Afghan chutney,
he added on some mayonnaise,
he added on some sauces, some ketchup,
then you could get different versions,
you can order different versions,
the chicken, the beef,
the, like, there's some
balogna-ish looking meat.
Basically, everything is deep-fried
and then stuffed within that bread
with the french fries and rolled up.
And from the outside, it's just
a mystery which one you get.
Could be the chicken, could be the beef.
- [Ali] You have to come to
my city to have this burger.
You have to come to Islamabad.
- Islamabad.
- [Joel] I haven't seen
anything about these things.
- The pride of Islamabad comes to food.
- [Mark] Is there a
strategy to eating this?
It's one of those things where
I don't think you should
unwrap the whole thing,
or you might lose things out the back end.
Maybe just unwrap the top.
- [Ali] Oh wow.
- Oh, some extra Afghan chutney!
Oh, that looks good!
Oh, wow.
- [Ali] It can explode any minute.
- [Mark] It's like a half a
bottle of mayonnaise in here!
(laughter)
- Sometimes you hold it, it's
about to explode, I mean.
- Cheers, guys, cheers.
(appreciative groaning)
- I got like an entire mouthful
of mayonnaise. (laughs)
Just a moundful of french fries,
like condensed into bread.
The chutneys, the masalas,
that's the unique thing about it,
is the masala blended with the mayonnaise.
Just dip it?
Just do the wipe, the wipe dip?
This might be the ultimate fast food
you can possibly have in the world.
Everything in one!
(appreciative groaning and laughing)
Definitely, actually, the
sauce, that Afghan chutney,
that is the best thing about it.
It's like vinager-y, it's really garlic-y.
I'm just gonna pour. (laughs)
After eating half of this,
I still don't know if I got the chicken
or the beef or the shishkebab,
and I don't think it really matters!
And that is the Afghani burger.
It's not something I would
eat on a daily basis,
but definitely at two
A.M. when you're hungry
and need something kinda
greasy, kinda oily.
That is exactly what you
would want to be eating,
and also it's just fun
to see them make it,
that's just like all
the things deep-fried,
wrapped up and mayonnaise-y.
(fans whirr)
Ali was explaining to me that Islamabad
is known for their burgers,
so people from Islamabad, they love,
throughout Pakistan,
from Karachi to Lahore,
Islamabad is known for
being burger lovers.
And so, we're at a place,
it's called Burger Fest.
The smoke is pouring, I love their slogan:
Let's Meat!
- [Ali] The Beef Binda.
- [Mark] Which looks like,
I don't even know what
that center layer is,
but it just looks like cheese
is just squeezing out of it.
(meat sizzles)
(restaurant chatter and chill groove)
We got one of the chicken,
one of the beef burgers.
For the beef, he grills the beef,
I like it, they use
hot, flaming charcoals.
Yeah, that's just like a good,
solid, hearty, beautiful looking burger.
This one is the Beef Binda burger.
That is a beautiful looking burger.
I love the sesame seeds on top.
Dude!
(excited chuckling)
Oh, that's beautiful!
(appreciative groaning)
Aala!
- (mumbling) Aala!
- Oh wow, by the way,
that's how you say oh wow in Urdu, right?
That is a solidly good burger,
the meat, the freshness of the meat,
and what's amazing,
this does taste like a Pakistani burger
because you taste that masala seasoning.
The beef is so crumbly.
The cheese, you taste the chili powder.
You can taste the chili powder in there!
- Chili powder and awesome pepper,
awesome black pepper.
- [Mark] Cumin, the cumin!
A mayonnaise foul.
- It's time for some burger swap.
- You wanna burger swap?
- Yeah.
- Okay, Ali's working on the chicken here.
How's that chicken, Ali?
- Chicken's pretty good.
- The Islamabad swap, the
must-needed one. (laughs)
Wow, that chicken is so tender.
And again, the smokiness
of the grill flavor.
We stood around and ate that burger
and met so many people just
standing around in that area.
One of the guys that we met,
he's like, oh yeah,
welcome to Burger-abad!
Islamabad is known for their burgers.
That was a really good burger,
and we've got one more
place to go in Islamabad.
It's that time of the day.
Ali is in the position.
- Caught blue-handed!
- Caught blue-handed.
- It's the time of the day
when we're all getting sleepy,
it's been a long day, but we're coming
to one more restaurant,
we're gonna order their,
we're gonna order some beef,
and I know they're famous
here for the fries,
which Ali said he comes to eat sometimes.
Reach in with the mayo.
- [Ali] If you want to
eat, eat Islamabad way.
- [Mark] The proper Islamabad way?
(laughs)
(chiming music)
There's that cheese.
- I just wanna eat my own fries,
end of the world right now.
- You guys really don't
know how to eat fries.
Come on, you're in Islamabad, man,
this is not how you eat fries.
- [Mark] So, Islamabad is known
for being very proper, right?
- Pakistan, this is how you eat fries.
- [Mark] Next up for the crazy panini,
and the crazy panini is one
of their specialties here.
Looks like it's filled
with, is that chicken?
Yeah, that is pretty good.
The melted cheese in there,
the chicken almost has kind of
a chicken curry flavor to it,
but that melty, oozy cheese
is what's holding it together.
That's making it really good.
And that wraps up this trip to Islamabad.
Let's go to Lahore!
(excited music)
Made it back to the
beautiful energy of Lahore!
I love this city!
We are here to first eat Lahore Broast,
and broast, I know it's chicken.
Broast, to me, sounds
kind of like a combination
of broiled and roasted.
I have no idea what it is.
Oh yeah, step inside,
and you could immediately
smell deep-friend-ness.
It appears that a broast
is not broiled or roasted,
but it's fried, and then
he put the lid down,
and it's like pressure cooked!
He stuck the lid down,
he cranked it tight.
That's gonna simmer away in the oil.
So that's like pressure deep fried.
Is it rice?
- [Cook] Steam, steam.
- [Mark] Oh, steam, oh nice.
- [Cook] Are you ready?
- [Mark] Yes!
So, how long did that
boil for, ten minutes?
Wow!
(oil popping)
They put the broast, they
broasted it, for ten minutes,
and then he just popped that cover.
You could hear the
pressure being released.
Our broast is ready!
Broast is just a fun word to say!
They put a handful of fries right on top,
and then we also got the steamed version,
another awesome thing that they serve
at this fast food restaurant
is a mutton joint.
(skin crunching)
Wow, that is incredibly crunchy, though!
Oh, oh that's hot!
- [Ali] Yeah, bite is good.
- It's so crunchy, too, it's
so crunchy, it's so crispy!
My first time ever to broast!
(crunching)
(laughter)
- I know you just burned your tongue.
- That's hot!
(crunching)
You have broast strategy?
- Don't expect any reaction,
I'm having for the millionth time.
(laughter)
- [Mark] Oh, so you come her often!
- I've grown up here, eating these.
- [Mark] I wanna broast with you.
(laughter)
(crunching and happy groaning)
- [Ali] The legit way to have the roast
is to have it with the chutney.
(appreciative groaning)
- Oh yeah, with the chutney, though.
Oh, that's what makes it unique!
So, a little bit sweet, but
you taste some spices in there,
and sour at the same time, it's tart.
Is this the steamed broast, or the--
- [Ali] It's the Degi Charghans.
- [Mark] Dig in the degi...
- [Ali] Degi Chargha, what
else you expect from chicken?
- [Mark] That's Degi Chargha!
(laughs)
That expert dip!
- I find it even better
than broast, by the way.
No offense to broast.
(appreciative grunting)
- Oh yeah, the steamed
is so much more flavor,
it's just caked in spices!
You taste the cinnamon-y flavors of it.
I prefer the steamed as well.
(appreciative grunting)
It's all come down to the joint.
This looks like a big drumstick.
- [Joel] It really does,
it looks exactly like a--
wait, is this mutton, or is this...
- [Ali] It's like a turkey.
- [Joel] It's like a turkey.
(appreciative groaning)
- Oh, all the mutton taste.
It's not like a joint,
though, it's the meat, too.
And then you've got the
cartilage-y bits as well.
Mutton joint is great!
(excited beat)
- Thank you!
- Thank you very much.
Especially my favorite thing
here was the degi chargha!
That had some great
spice, some great chili,
that was wonderful!
Hello, how are you?
- I've seen you so many times!
(excited music)
(sizzling and restaurant chatter)
(clattering of spatulas)
We're here to eat something
called the Bun Plaster!
This is something I've never had before,
and it looks amazing,
but his street food cooking
skills are just remarkable!
He takes, I think that's butter at first,
he scoops some butter onto the hot plate,
and that just sizzles away,
then he throws down the egg,
then he throws down, like he
does everything so fluidly,
so quickly, he then cracks
an egg onto the hot plate,
he throws down the buns,
and he just perfectly, yet artistically,
tosses down the bun onto the egg,
coating the egg, then he takes one of the,
I believe it's like a potato fritter,
he puts that onto the hot plate.
He gives it a little smack
with his little hard metal spatula,
that just flattens it perfectly.
He sticks that into the bun.
Everything's so rhythmic,
everything's so fast,
with a rhythm, so artistic!
Yeah, this is beautiful to watch him
as he makes this Bun Plaster.
That looks like another treat
that you wanna be eating
at two A.M. in the morning.
(sizzling and clattering)
He has absolutely mastered the art
of flipping, sliding, and flattening
things on the hot griddle.
Have you ever had a Bun Plaster before?
- I haven't had it before,
but this plaster joint is right near
the National College of Arts,
so having this plaster
makes you more creative.
- [Mark] And this entire Bun Plaster
is extremely creative!
He could so this with his eyes closed,
that's without a doubt!
He could Bun Plaster with his eyes closed!
- [Ali] How did it get it's name? (laugh)
- [Mark] We should ask him!
- [Ali] (asking in Urdu)
So, there's actually like
a history behind this name.
You see, the way you plaster a wall,
so you take cement, and then
you put it on top of it,
this is the way, for example,
you have your bread and then
you plaster it with egg.
- It really does have
to do with construction!
That's beautiful, and sitting
on the side of the street,
this is a beautiful location.
I just love Lahore.
The entire thing could be
a newly constructed wall!
Oh, that's hot!
It's all plastered together.
Bun Plaster cheers?
- Cheers!
(smooth groove)
- This is really good,
and I'm amazed that they are serving it
without chutney, chutney is so good.
But, I don't know.
- Oh, it's pretty awesome.
I gotta give that a big thumbs up,
it's delicious, actually,
and it's all plastered
together with the cement!
It's really, awesomely good!
I thought it was a potato patty,
but it's actually a
lentil and chicken patty.
That's why it tastes so good.
(appreciative grunting)
I'm a big fan of the Bun Plaster.
- That was really good, man,
I mean, burger without a
chutney, yet it taste so good,
and I'm having on more, and I
think I'm gonna have two more.
Maybe a third one, the
hunger pangs that I'm having.
- [Mark] They love the
Bun Plaster so much,
they got seconds, second Bun Plasters!
I've gotta admit, that Bun
Plaster is one of my favorite
Western Continental Pakistani foods
that we've had so far on this tour.
That's just absolutely delicious!
Simple, but just genius combination!
That was delicious.
When you come to Lahore,
a Bun Plaster is a must.
(street chatter)
Next up in Lahore, we are at a place,
it's called Yousaf Falooda Shop,
and they're very well-known
for all sorts of milk-based desserts,
and even just fresh milk.
You can come here and
drink a glass of milk,
but we're gonna order a
couple of their desserts,
and there's also another drink,
which is called Doodh Pepsi,
which is, doodh means
milk, Pepsi is Pepsi,
so it's where you mix milk and Pepsi.
I'm not totally sure they're ratio,
but actually, it's
common to drink at home,
and people drink it like
to settle their stomach,
it's just kinda maybe for fun,
I've never had it before,
so we decided we're gonna
try some of their desserts,
and then we'll ask them,
they don't actually
serve Doodh Pepsi here,
it's typically drinked at home,
but since they have
such good quality milk,
we're gonna ask them if they
can also mix that for us,
and we'll taste that along with
all the rest of the desserts as well.
Kheer?
- Kheer.
- Kulfi Falooda.
- [Mark] Kulfi Falooda.
- Rasmalai.
- [Mark] Rasmalai.
And this one?
- Pepsi Doodh, Pepsi milk.
- [Mark] Pepsi milk.
- Amazing collection of sweets.
- This place is a legendary
place in Lahore, right?
It's been here.
This one is the Kulfi...
- [Ali] Falooda.
- [Mark] Kulfi Falooda, which is,
Kulfi is the ice cream, which
is plunked right into there.
(appreciative grunting)
Oh, that's almost cheesy!
- Yeah.
- Wow!
Okay, here it is, my first
time to try a Doodh Pepsi.
I think his ratio was
about three quarters milk,
to a quarter Pepsi, that
was about right, right?
- [Ali] Yup.
- That's actually not bad! (laughs)
Because, like, it really
mellows out the Pepsi!
It's milky, and you just taste
a little bit of the carbonation!
Oh yeah, there's something in my ear.
You can kind of feel like that
would be good at digestion,
it kind of just goes down,
kinda feels like energizing,
yeah, like, mellow.
- I believe that's more than a drink.
- That is not bad!
(laughs)
- You know what I believe,
more than a drink, this
is a cultural diplomacy.
East and west meeting in one drink.
It's like a cocktail of cultures.
Now it's come down to my most favorite,
the ultimate kheer.
(appreciative groaning)
- Yeah, you are right.
Oh yeah, it's not too sweet,
it's kind of like pudding.
Like, it's the texture of pudding,
but with little more texture to it,
not quite as smooth, and then again,
you taste the cardamom in there.
Halfway between butter and yogurt.
There is one more thing
that we're gonna do
to complete this entire
food tour and experience.
Pepsi is throwing a huge event.
We are headed there now,
and that's going to complete this entire
Western Pakistani Continental food tour
across three of the most
major cities in Pakistan!
(chattering in Urdu)
- So we have Mark Weins with us,
what do you feel about Pakistan?
- I think it's amazing that...
(music swells)
(party chatter)
- [Speaker] All right,
ladies and gentlemen,
he travels around the
world for the love of food,
and yes ladies and gentlemen,
I'm talking about the
renowned food blogger,
Mark Weins in the house!
A big round of applause,
he's here, he came this far!
- This is cotton candy and (mumbling).
- Cheers?
- Cheers!
- [Speaker] All right!
(bass beats)
- Hey, everyone, it's Mark Wiens,
and I just wrapped up a 16
day food and travel trip,
more than a trip, it was an experience
and a journey through Pakistan!
- For the second time in Pakistan,
please just tell us about your journey
and your association with Pepsi now.
- Yeah, second trip to Pakistan
and again, it's been an
amazing trip, more than a trip,
we've met so many people along the way.
- Right.
- And this time, it
was such a warm welcome
that it was almost like coming home!
- Coming back to home.
(music thrums)
- You don't have to have only seafood,
you could even have this kind of stuff,
kind of mix it up a little bit.
- I'm very happy to be in Pakistan,
thank you always for the warm welcome!
- [Camera Woman] One, two, three, go!
(laughter)
- [Joel] Spread between yourselves,
and look at Mark's face behind you.
This is on video.
- Oh, look at Mark.
- [Joel] It's just awesome.
(laughter)
- [Mark] We have come to the end
of this Western Pakistani
Continental food tour.
We went from Karachi to Islamabad,
finally finishing in Lahore
with this Pepsi event.
It's the warm welcome, the generosity,
really like, this second
trip, coming back to Pakistan
has felt like it's,
people have welcomed us,
like we're coming home,
and so I wanna say a massive thank you
to everyone in Pakistan,
and I wanna say a huge thank you to Pepsi
for sponsoring this video,
for making this happen,
for inviting us back to Pakistan.
I wanna say a huge thank you to Zaid
and to everyone on the team
for their incredible support.
Massive thank you to
Ali, my good friend Ali,
again for helping, for
taking care of the logistics.
What an amazing trip,
what an amazing time,
I cannot wait for my next
trip back to Pakistan again.
What's up guys!
- Promise you'll be back, Mark!
Promise you'll be back!
- We'll be back for sure,
we'll be back for sure!
Okay, so that's gonna end this video,
I wanna say a huge thank you
to you for watching this video,
please remember to give it a thumbs up
if you enjoyed it, leave a comment below,
I'd love to hear from you,
and if you're not already subscribed,
click subscribe now and also
click that little bell icon
so that you get notified of
the next video that I publish.
Thanks again for watching,
goodbye from Pakistan,
see you on the next video!